laissez moi aujourd'hui vous parler d'un
smartphone qui est un champion
d'autonomie c'est pas le smartphone le
plus fin
c'est pas le smartphone qui va faire les
plus belles photos c'est pas le
photophone c'est pas une bête de
puissance mais par contre c'est une bête
d'autonomie et c'est surtout un
smartphone il coûte moins de 300 euros
et qui à ce prix là est vraiment top
[Musique]
je vais directement commander pas vous
dire à qui se destine ce smartphone
avant même de vous le présenter et avant
de même de quoi vous en parler ce
smartphone s'est fait [ __ ] dans la
boîte c'est le sinn fein max pro m2 et
le m2 c'est une vraie bête de compet en
autonomie il s'adresse aux personnes qui
veulent un smartphone endurant pas trop
cher qui pourra faire un petit peu tout
sans en faire trop
il est là il est plutôt bien il est
plutôt qu'aux règles les photos vont pas
être dingue l'écran est correct c'est
pas là vous allez avoir la meilleure
expérience multimédia
mais c'est là vous allez avoir passé
maul terme aux smartphones increvable si
son gros point fort et ça pour 299 euros
croyez moi c'est vraiment très très très
bien voilà comment ça se passe vous avez
cette jolie boîte là vous avez le joli
smartphones vont lui je veux revenir
dessus dans quelques instants d'abord
commencer par la boîte elle s'ouvre
comme ça vous faites glisser we love
photos ici dans cette petite boîte je
vous soutiens de boxing très très très
rapide pour vous puissiez voir qu'il ya
à l'intérieur et comment ça se passe
vous avez une petite coque de protection
transparente les cartes de garantie les
cils et saha les numéros de série tout
va bien vous venez ouvrir la porte
octobre qui a gros blocs de charme
vous avez des écouteurs avec une prise
jack
parce que oui il ya une prise jack
conservés dans ce produit des embouts
pour s'adapter à toutes les morphologies
à toutes les oreilles
et ici vous avez votre câble de recharge
alors c'est l'un poule où le bât blesse
de notre côté on va un petit peu si tu
es truc vous avez de la recharge usb et
là vous avez la recharge micro usb car
oui ce smartphone se recharge en micro
usb
alors je vous dis tout de suite il va
falloir prendre son mal en patience où
sont mes notes
mes petites notes sont là pour recharger
à 100% ça vous prendra
qu'est ce que j'écris mal c'est
incroyable qu'est ce que j'écris mal de
fois que je me fais peur ça avec eux
petit aparté je comprends mes profs de
collège dit c'est qu'il peut aussi faire
des cahiers d'écriture bon ça n'a servi
strictement rien et je les comprends
2h30 pour le recharger en entier il faut
avoir prévu parce que si vous n'avez pas
prévu si vous levez le matin oui peu la
plus battre
eh bien vous êtes un petit peu mal à
moins d'avoir une power banque à côté ce
qui pourrait faire la faire c'est par
smartphone que vous aller recharger
rapidement en une demi-heure une heure
non il vous faut 2h30 on n'a pas de
recharge rapide on a une grosse batterie
de 5000 militants terreur donc il faut
la nourrir il faut lui en mettre dedans
il faut donc prendre son mal en patience
mais dans la mesure vous avait anticipé
la problématique vous l'avez recharger
soit pendant la nuit soit la veille où
un moment où vous allez avoir deux
heures et demie de libre devant vous et
bien vous allez pouvoir tenir deux jours
sans problème
alors oui deux jours sans problème si
vous n'êtes pas un sauvage et barbare et
si vous n'êtes pas tout le temps dessus
a joué pendant des heures et à paramé
les yeux et être tout le temps dit qui
est génial escales autour de vous il
faut aussi fallu un petit peu les yeux
il a un peu décroché
ah oui qui me veut je décroche désolé je
raccroche est si vous êtes tous temps
dessus vous cadrez qu'une journée par
contre si vous avez une utilisation
modérée deux jours et si vous êtes hyper
cool peut-être grappiller quelques
heures plus sas intéressante c'est
vraiment de très très gros point fort de
smartphones et je le recommande à toutes
les personnes qui ont des gros besoins
en termes d'autonomie qui sont pas des
gourmands ou gourmandes et qui veulent
un smartphone plutôt cool à côté de ça
vous à nos smartphones qui est bien
fabriqué qui est cool
vous avez un d'eau en plastique juste
ici
qui va laisser des traces de doigts
alors bon ça c'est pas une nouveauté
vous aviez un dos plastique ou un dos en
verre aujourd'hui sur ce genre de
matériau on a forcément des traces de
doigts c'est pas bien grave
vous le voyez si le petit branding asus
le capteur d'empreintes digitales qui
est franchement hyperactif très rapide
1 2 3 je pose ils iront vite ça va il y
en a qui filent et plutôt bien module
photo ici alors on va en parler dans
quelques instants vous avez sur le côté
le bouton de volume bouton pour
l'allumer pour l'éteindre haut parleur
mono vous leur charge et si je vous le
dis en micro usb
le micro prise jack vous avez ici une
double sim et vous avez ici votre micro
plat réduction de bruit petit haut
parleur en eau qui se cache là avec une
led de notification qui est ici pas si
vous la voyez les clignote et vous avez
un écran avec une encoche alors on aime
on n'aime pas moi en tout cas vu le
placement de ce smartphone
ça ne dérange pas vous avez des bords
qui sont quand même relativement fin sur
le côté et un menton qui est un peu plus
proéminente ça c'est pas anormal on est
sur un smartphone à 299 euros
on va pas non plus lui demander la lune
tout en tout cas que d'un pote du
conception il est très honnête bien
résistant enfin je trouve en tout cas
c'est résistance allégé
quelque 175 g vous avez un écran lcd une
dan ip s de 6,3 pouces de diagonale 2280
par 1080 pixels c'est un format 19/9
c'est ce qui se fait beaucoup
aujourd'hui sur les smartphones il est
plutôt pas mal alors moi je trouve 15
ans a tiré un petit peu sur le côté
bleuté voix légèrement violine être mes
yeux qui sont un peu bizarres
là vous vous en rendrez pas content
parce que la colorimétrie sur l'image
vous avez ce côté un petit peu bleuté il
est absolument impossible de venir
corriger ça directement dans votre
affichage
vous pouvez par contre avoir une petite
éclairage nocturne qui va venir diminué
c'était un peu bleuté moi ce que je vous
conseille quand même très honnêtement
c'est de l'activer en permanence il
signale qu'à ça tout petit peu ça va le
devenir très très très légèrement mais
je trouve que c'est quand même un petit
peu mieux
vous pouvez aussi par choix d'adapter la
luminosité des façon automatique
pourquoi pas bon ça ça marche pas près
du point de vue loes je redis très très
rapidement mais on tourne sur un android
stockent salle android 8.1 oreo alors
pour tous ceux qui ne sauraient pas ce
que veut dire android stockent c'est un
androïde 100% dire qu'on n'a pas de
surcouche fabricant asus n'a absolument
pas mis de surcouche tout ce que vous
avez là c'est 100% android c'est 100%
google pointe et pas mal c'est que il
est assez lumineux en plein jour lorsque
vous allez dehors aujourd'hui une belle
journée ensoleillée
je me suis mis dehors en tulle je sais
je ne doute de rien j'aime via
transpirait que voulez vous même pas et
du coup ça va on voit bien lorsque vous
mettez la luminosité à fond et que vous
êtes au soleil il est effet lumineux
ça c'est aussi pas mal côté désuet de
vidéo je vous le disais ils ont rendu
est plutôt bien alors là je vais
vraiment poussé à fond les trois formats
19/9 match haut en 16 9ème donc je viens
comme ça il ya du son la gym ils sont à
fond avec le petit haut parleur mono ça
dégage quand même à 7 sont le son est
assez médium on n'a pas beaucoup de
corps pas beaucoup de graves de notre
côté on est sur un smartphone c'est pas
anormal et ça fait franchement la faire
quatre employés l'audio là je suis
directement sur un jeu sur astra qmi
trop ça sature le haut parleur a un peu
mal encaissé donc pour profiter d'une
qualité audio qui ne sature pas il faut
baisser parce que là c'est pour tous les
côtés parce qu'à défaut de ce smartphone
c'est que besoins des pigeons qui tu as
fait micro
ça marche plutôt pas mal quand on jette
pas sa voiture tous les côtés ça va ça
va il est bien alors on va pas mettre
des jeux trop gourmand c'est pas une
bête de compet un tour sur la dragonne
660 on a six genia drame alors si giga
de ram ça vous apporte de la fluidité et
ça c'est aussi super cool
vous avez 64 giga de stockage dans la
machine extensible jusqu'à 2 terreur ça
aussi c'est un mois ça aussi c'est
vachement bien
oh la vache le carnage du coup tout ça
nous apporte de la fluidité ça c'est
cool et je vous parlais justement
multimédia je vous parlais de jo je suis
très content que asus et laisser cette
triste jacques dessus merci à juste à
côté de ça le sont au niveau du casque
est pas complètement dingue on n'a pas
un sens furieux il nous manque du
spectre un peu plus grave ça ronronne ça
ronronne pas à côté de ça il ya du son
qui est assez correcte pas énormément de
puissance de la côte est une fois de
plus je vous le dis ne poussez pas le
son trop fort dans vos casques vous
risquez de vous rendre sourd
ça serait vraiment vraiment vraiment
dommage le spectre est pas dingue
néanmoins ça permet d'écouter de la
musique correctement des vidéos
tranquillement de joies des jeux
correctement et à 299 euros donc il faut
vraiment resituer le smartphone dans sa
catégorie prix dans sa fourchette de
prix on est sur un smartphone moins
exigeants quinzaine phone 5.55 z
concernant la partie photo que vous avez
double caméra ici vous avez une caméra
principale de 12 mégapixels clk faire le
job avec une ouverture de f 1.8 et vous
avez au dessus une caméra de 5
mégapixels qui est là pour le mode
portrait pour les débloquer un petit
flash ici parce que forcément des fois
on a besoin d'un petit renfort de
lumières et vous avez ici à l'avant une
caméra de 13 mégapixels qui ouvre à f
2.0
dans l'absolu rendu photo est pas
complètement fou là on est sur un beau
buzz tartam jeu désolé pour tous les
amis vegan pareil le même plat prix du
dessus que vous avez là là on a des
petites feuilles une petite fleur le
point c'est bien fait dessus
on y fera sur un photophone de ouf quant
à la continuation de photos avec de la
nature voyez cette règle insee le
printemps toujours la même chose petit
feuillage et on arrive la nuit je vous
ai pris la lune on a forcément beaucoup
de bruit on s'est un peu les limites de
ce capteur là en photo nue à vous
ramener beaucoup de bruit il va ramener
du grain je me porterai vous
et un flou d'arrière plan qui est pas
mal la voyez typiquement il détour quand
même pas trop mal le doit au niveau du
visage ça va alors il a un peu de mal au
niveau des zones de plus de cheveux ici
aussi tout un petit peu plus grisé alors
vous pouvez même film est là dessus en
4k à 30 images par seconde
personnellement je vous conseille de
rester sur du full hd si vous voulez
avoir le maximum de qualité pour vos
vidéos c'est ce qui ira le mieux c'est
un smartphone gadio fc pour le paiement
dématérialisé pour tous les pas des
transports en commun vous et pour son
smartphone vous pouvez le faire grâce à
ça serait plutôt pas mal en plus vous
avez du bluetooth 5.0 vous avez double
sim et vous n'avez pas certification ip
donc pas certifié étanche contre les
gouttes d'eau et contre la poussière
alors rassurez vous on est sur un
smartphone milieu de gamme entre et
milieu de gamme c'est pas surprenant
qu'il ait pas certification ip néanmoins
s'il rencontre un petit peu d'eau ne lui
cache et pas directement dans une poche
étanche ça va ça devrait quand même
plutôt bien se passer par contre éviter
de le jeter dans la cuvette des
toilettes
si toutefois vous avez envie de faire le
test donc voilà je trouve très honnête
c'est tout ce smartphone
la grande force et je vous le dis une
fois de plus c'est qu'il est une grosse
batterie de 5000 ayant paire eur point
un petit peu faible ça va être le temps
de recharge deux ans et demi ça peut
être long prévoyez le coup néanmoins
vous le savez vous êtes maintenant
informés à côté de ça il ya un ensemble
qui est cohérent la photo est pas
exceptionnel l'écran est bien pour du
multimédia pareil la prise jack
elle n'est pas complètement folle mais
une fois de plus pour un smartphone à
299 euros
il fait la sphère dites moi vous ce que
vous en pensez en bas juste en dessous
en commentaire est ce que vous le
trouver intéressant est ce que il
pourrait vous tenter et qu'est ce que
vous pensez des zus au niveau des
smartphones
on parle bien du smartphone qu'est ce
que vous en pensez l'année dernière il
ya eu notamment tout ce qui y est j'y
viens tu veux manger un oeuf kinder ce
n'est pas de la pub pour kinder elliott
ce qu'il est il est 18h30 de ses peurs
d'un jeune homme qui meurt si t'es
mignon après le repas tout rock it off
kingdom hearts and the papas et c'est
parce que ceux qui couvrent surprise
bouftou et ben tu ouvres l'oeuf kinder
tu le manges pas toujours la surprise
malin papa ouvre la ringer non tu le
manges pas après leur précieux le
mangerait après nos pas exactement ça
sa cheikh où aller fils route
je vous disais qu'est ce que vous pensez
des zus est ce que vous aimez la marque
oui non comment vous la trouvez les
gardiens a sorti notamment en haut de
gamme le iphone 5 0 et c'est vraiment un
bon smartphone et dites moi ce que vous
pensez de syphon max pro m2 en bas en
commentaire à 299 morts d'ailleurs si
vous intéresse vous ai mis un lien juste
en bas dans la description
voilà un rendez vous demain vous
embrasse et je vais vérifier qu'ils
mangent pas dans neuf länder mal